in most US cities parking is a drag
parking garages are expensive and
parking on the street can be a real
hassle if you're lucky enough to find an
empty parking spot you still have to
find enough change to feed the meter and
then if your errands take longer than
expected you run the risk of getting a
parking ticket just a few years ago
Indianapolis had the same old fashioned
parking meters you find in most cities
in the u.s. we were using the old same
technology from 35 years ago you put
quarters are your dimes and nickels in
they were pretty ugly we tackled this
one again put out requests for
information what were people thinking
what could we do we wind up with four
pretty solid proposals we picked one
with a group called Park Indy it is a 50
year contract the city has the
opportunity to opt out every ten years
we operate and manage the system
everything from meter collection
estimator maintenance and now instead of
putting those quarters in and you know
that the classic scene from the 1950s
that's not what happens anymore now
people can use debit cards they can use
credit cards it's all electronic we have
sensors in the ground so you could find
a parking spot so you can look at your
phone and it will tell you where the
parking spot is in the area that you're
looking parking to your left
Indianapolis drivers with smart phones
can also use an app to pay the same app
allows people to set an alarm where the
meter is about to expire and extend the
parking time if they need to but the
city have done that by themself
absolutely not
in 2010 the old city run parking meter
system generated less than $100,000 the
new meters managed by Park Indy
generated more than 1.4 million dollars
for the city the first year they were
operational and over the course of the
50 year lease the city is projected to
make a lot of cash the estimates for
that or anywhere between 350 to 600
million dollars over life
and that's on top of an upfront payment
to the city of 20 million dollars of
course in order to make the deal work
the city had to increase parking meter
rates our rates were so cheap it was
unbelievable
it was like 75 cents an hour something
like that and I think they went into a
buck and a half an hour immediately it's
hardly non-competitive and as I tell
people I don't have salary I don't have
pensions I don't have infrastructure
cost I don't have maintenance cost I
don't have insurance cost I just take
the money now we're gonna do this for
the next 50 years and that money has to
be used for infrastructure so we've
essentially Kirsch created a very strong
infrastructure fund which is
significantly more than if we just left
it the way it was why don't more cities
pursue these kinds of public-private
partnerships
I'm stunned by the number of government
officials who don't seem to like the
word profit like they don't want a
company to make a profit when they work
with the government I'm thinking why not
the parking deal is is the perfect
example they're making a profit and I'm
getting more money if the city is
getting more money what is wrong with
that picture
you